you rollin yeah so it's Tuesday
yes United States of America last night
our favorite German because he was
deported for all the spelling mistakes
he's making in the videos last year I
just got his house
you wanna go visit you sure he's that
he's there right now no he's not stuck
in customs hopefully is there what do
you call it when you like put meat in
and like a liquid to let it like soak up
there no marinate yeah that's where we
marinated all the street meat familiar
faces worn out places worn out faces and
this street meat guy I want some more
street meat don't like I've tried to
sneeze pulled up
so there's no secret that we make a lot
of nerve videos somebody asked us if
it'd be cool to send us a mod for the
hammer shop orange mod works is the guy
that sends over this is it thinks up to
give you more velocity as well as a
metal hammer I'm gonna open this up here
see we got the metal hammer new spring
whole new fancy cylinder
maybe we should shoot this see how far
it goes and see what happens after I
install the mod have a chronograph here
but tell me how fast these darts are
traveling so let's see 58 feet per
second 67 47 67 so somewhere between
high 50s mid 60's let's check our
distance those starts go really far so
they're about at like Jake's desk all
right let's go mod this thing I've done
zero in dirt mods Sam's done a whole
bunch let's see what happens ok kids
video let's get the most views on
YouTube their entire channel is
dedicated to kids opening candy and
getting toys and candy and all kind of
stuff there are no regulations as to
what you can need to make and against
video on YouTube it might be worth
investigating this I may be making a
video about it hey go thanks Steve you
just have that met
all makes a good first impression for
Carmichael
you know and now I get you all right
let's see you there
I'm a Sith Lord when I was in high
school people said I looked like Hayden
Christensen from Star Wars cars here
quiet
you
[Applause]
Ren and Nick you look so German I know
so did you pass your English test to be
able to get back in the country by
sheesh man these next four years gonna
be rough for you dude
flatly oh he's liebe dich all right I
think this is ready to be opened oh wow
look at that plunger
okay so at this point if I move the
hammer the trigger should move at the
same time okay it's working everything
will hopefully work I had to put 13
screws into this gun so one second here
so how was Europe because you guys
didn't go did only Germany we went to
Paris for a week then we went to London
then we went to Bordeaux had two bottles
of wine a day and then we went to
Germany and then I visited my monk of an
uncle some your muckle deadlift the guy
think he's up basically Buddhism he went
to the Himalaya temples stayed there for
five years he straight up gave up
everything and went there now he's back
welcome back to a rainy Los Angeles
classic very very classic weather type
here we see it all the time
[Music]
well that was thoroughly unpleasant all
right we're all set
we got a sit metal trigger we've got a
sick metal hammer and I got a six
cylinder that holds one extra bullet all
right let's go see how fast this shoots
64
5762
I consider this a perfect gun before it
was modded let's see if it just got more
perfect yeah yeah shooting a little bit
harder the actual metal hammer is so
cool man that that's got a funky yeah it
shoot starts there's a little bit harder
thankfully it doesn't actually up the
danger quotient too much this gives you
one more shot and it also feels way
cooler this yak you see some style
points cuz of the weight of this hammer
just for something that was considerably
painful good shot thug life